hello and a very warm welcome to this
latest edition of talking Germany the
show where we do just that of my guest
today is a remarkable man he's crossed
the Atlantic on a tree trunk true story
he's been ambushed over two dozen times
he's been strangled by a Python and he
has even eaten worms and here is thank
you very very much for joining us here
on talking Germany today now as an
adventurer rüdiger Newburg made a name
as the man who introduced survival
training to Germany and indeed to the
rest of Europe in recent years he's
earned a reputation as an activist a
human rights activist and above all as
an extremely effective campaigner
against female circumcision so we've got
a lot to talk about today Rudy get that
I want to begin by talking about snakes
I love snake why do you love snakes
other people are frightened of snakes
you love them yeah tell them unfold
yawns but I think you lose your fear of
animals when you know their strengths
and weaknesses I know it was snakes I'm
faster I know that when they strike I
have to get outside a certain radius I
once led a 5 meter Python test strangle
me top to toe
yet mija bitten me here but I was
wearing a thick jacket I did bite your
neck and holds on clipping its body
around you and I thought it means that
all expected to run out of air but it
was just like somebody hugging me but
then I wanted to breathe man couldn't
get any air because it was wrapped
around me I had to exhale more deeply
and immediately it tightened its hold on
a rib after 60 seconds I was exhausted I
took it back into its room and suddenly
I was dripping with sweat my heart was
pounding as if I were reliving it
doesn't know I know after half an hour
the sweating was over my heart was calm
again and I felt great as
had a fabulous massage if you want to
try it it was a rock python heads and
Putin fascinating stuff and we get it we
get a feel for the way you work we get a
feel for how you you in your life you've
tested your body if you've you've opened
yourself up to challenges and you made
that your career because your career
certainly to begin with was based on
what they call survival training for our
audience give me a definition of
survival training what is it survival is
for me to me survival means returning to
the basic instincts of every animal that
lives in the wild in Germany the term
was unknown even in the Bundeswehr it
was known to the SAS and in America and
I imported it from there because I was
enthusiastic about it it extended my
abilities to survive alone in the wild
in the desert let's see in the jungle
even naked and that broadened my
horizons so much gave me opportunities
that later brought me to my human rights
work because I became an eyewitness to
dreadful proceedings the Yanomami tribes
in Brazil were threatened with genocide
and now the crime of female genital
mutilation can eat our [ __ ] milk okay
you've had your first impressions there
from Rudy Gerner back he is more Wiggin
a VAX living room is both his museum and
where he fuels his energies on its walls
hang mementos of his many adventures at
an age when others are putting their
feet up nee Baga and his wife Annette de
are planning their next project
the trained pastry cook says daily
routine was never his thing he's always
looking for adventure in the 1970s he
crossed the Danakil desert in Ethiopia
on foot he crossed the Atlantic three
times
Neb egg brought the notion of survival
to Germany and he showed stressed
managers how to live in the wild
you have to learn to overcome discussed
and socially related preconceptions like
worms are disgusting you eat what you
have to when there's no alternative
and these people taught me that life as
an adventurer has its price
neighbor ugh has been robbed 25 times on
his trips to the ends of civilization in
1975 on the Blue Nile in Ethiopia
robbers shot his friend Misha had ties
one dead neighbor and a guide just
managed to get to safety above Adam
Peter found find a flight was the
longest unbroken period of fear in my
life because we always knew that they
were following us intending to silence
us as witnesses so it couldn't be proven
that they'd murdered him that meet money
needed a mortician avoid stuff even
after his friend's death
Nyberg never thought about giving up
life as an adventurer especially a few
years later when it gained new
significance deep in the Brazilian
rainforest one of the world's last
indigenous tribes the Yanomami were
under threat gold prospectors were
destroying their habitat neighbor
informed the world among other things
with his spectacular Atlantic crossings
after 20 years and a lot of to do the
lobby was so big that Brazil had to
change its constitution and really
secure this territory for the Yanomami
now they've been living in relative
peace since 2000 it's my toes and I'm a
puppet of freedom since then 13 years
have passed during which booty good
neighbor egg and his wife found a new
challenge the fight against a crime
perpetrated against nearly 150 million
women around the world and by which
every day
eight thousand girls undergo torture
Amina was one of them female
circumcision is customary among
oh jesus meters wealth had been
subjected to this mutilation ten weeks
before and never uttered a word after
that she was struck dumb with horror
fright and shock and that's what touched
us so much rudiger and Annette and a bag
started the caravan of hope their aim is
to awaken revulsion against genital
mutilation though many people use the
Koran to justify it the book doesn't
even mention this appalling procedure in
2006 neighbor and his wife managed to do
the incredible they got together with
the most important Muslim religious
leaders at a conference in Cairo and the
leaders branded female circumcision a
sin the Baker and doctors receptionist
from rostov triumphed over a bestial
5000 year old ritual I can't imagine a
more wonderful moment that was the
breakthrough no now the word has to be
spread and I think we can do that didn't
get a shuffle yet the problem is that
the good news from Cairo has yet to
reach the most remote corners of the
world in 35 countries girls are still
being mutilated
every preacher in every village should
be announcing that this brutal ritual is
a sin Amina is also now helping she's
become blue tiga and Annette and a bags
god child was touching for me was that
this girl who was once struck down can
now offer her own daughters this trial
is for she passes it on happy and her
daughter's face a future without
mutilation we were very personally
touched because she's been with us for
such a long time a big lighted the
neighbors greatest wish is that
everywhere in the world people will know
that genital mutilation is a sin they've
already saved this baby girl I live a
wonderful scene at the end of a
fascinating life I'd like to go back
Rudi goodnight Bert writes at the
beginning when you were I don't know how
old you were exactly you were three
years old or four years old there are
different versions of the story and that
was when you went on your first
adventure tell us about it I was
equipped in benefit I was living in
Bielefeld and I had a grandmother there
who had dried apples back then during
the war that was a sensation I wanted to
go there and got completely lost walking
there after two days the police found me
sleeping under a rhododendron bush and
brought me home after that my mother
kept a close eye on me so I wouldn't do
it again but at 17 I had my own bicycle
wears one gear and a small luggage rack
and I set out on my own again I told my
parents I was planning to go to Paris
I had a friend there and gave him 15
postcards he sent them one every week
and meanwhile I cycled the merit cache
in Morocco to learn snake-charming when
I came back my parents heard that I
hadn't been in Paris at all but in
Marrakech they were really happy man
from then on I was free to do what I
wanted a happy or fond an apparition on
fiight back to the beginning again you
were three or four years old you were
this big and you were away from home for
two days
were you not frightened
I don't remember that day I stole body
so young by this time I think I was so
young that I didn't have any fear and at
that age you're carefree but later when
it was clear that I was going to the
Blue Nile in Ethiopia where lots of
shooting was going on an expedition of
70 British soldiers were shot out that
was another thing entirely and I always
knew and analyzed before every trip what
might happen and I tried to prepare
myself for any eventuality by training
for I learned to shoot from the hill on
the ocean with the boat I had a shotgun
that was like a machine gun because of
pirates I had enough drinking water my
tree was unsinkable it was idiot-proof
and then this idiot goes from Africa to
America because the currents and trade
winds go that way and I didn't have to
do anything
jung-hwa DeStorm oh won't you sit there
and watch the ocean and at some point
you arrived ballbuster Dino channeled a
young one Amanda let's go back to that
let's go back to that very early trip
when he was 17 years old and you went to
Morocco we talked about snakes you went
to Morocco to learn about snake charming
yeah did you learn how to do it yeah
that's claw yes
the trick is snakes can't hear and when
a cobra is frightened it rears up
spreads its hood so it looks bigger and
hisses then you have it in a basket and
opener stunts you stay at a distance
because when the snake is up so high
that's how far it can strike and you
have a flute to keep it at a distance
fluid has a large gourd at the end of it
and the snake smells me with its tongue
and then I play it doesn't hear me
but the spectators do and they think how
musical and when I start to move it does
to vary symmetrically forwards and back
and that's the trick you use the snakes
natural behavior to fool people citric
minutest are not truly his fire hose of
loiter so far how can
we mentioned it in the report that we
just saw the it was mentioned in passing
that you were actually when you were
still a very young man you were a baker
of all things you the adventurer were a
baker what yeah well he gave a hoof
didn't make us up mean he had forget me
and being a professional Baker wasn't
fulfilling for me it fed me and I had to
decide on a profession when I was only
15 it was after the war we were hungry
and I wanted something crisis proof so I
became a baker but I always had the aim
of becoming self-sufficient to stay
independent in order to pursue my hobby
of traveling on my own alone in the
desert and elsewhere and I succeeded but
at some point as I witnessed the
terrible events in Brazil my day job
became a burden and I was glad to sell
my big grateful and and spend all my
time traveling for human rights
no mention vegetarian
it's all very colorful it's all very
inspiring it's fascinating to listen to
you talking about it but you just
mentioned the fact that sometimes there
were incidents that were very difficult
to digest extremely frightening moments
as during the trip on the Blue Nile when
you lost a friend yeah what happened
exactly yeah blow would Neal the Blue
Nile was seen as terra incognita
thousands of kilometers of untouched
africa that's what drew me crocodiles
malaria mosquitoes tsetse flies
hippopotami that was my world was
crocodile proof and unsinkable it
wouldn't break down but then one day
after two weeks we were waylaid one
morning 12 people were standing there
all are from their faces covered up but
that was normal it was cold in the
mornings my friend approached them and
wanted to say hello and then they all
raised their guns started to shoot hit
my friend and they hit he was dead on
the spot we to others me in a Swiss man
realized it was serious there was no
warning shots and we didn't know that my
friend was right next to you yeah but I
yes but I thought he'd thrown himself on
the ground to protect himself but in
reality he was dead we reacted me to
what the men had not seen was that we
wore survival belts under our shirts and
that included a revolver the cartridges
were insulated against moisture and
after our first shot they all fled into
the forest and we could take advantage
of their confusion to flee down the
river we're on the run for five days
then we reach civilization and got in
touch from the German Embassy in a
manhunt was organized and they caught
the culprits we talked a little bit
about survival training you were the
person who introduced survival training
to Germany and you're telling me stories
about hardships and adventures that you
were on when you do survival training
why do you do it what is the what is the
threat what is the disaster or the
catastrophe that you want to survive if
I taught I thought money because it
broadens my life I can allow myself
trips to places no one else can get to
whether I'm alone in the jungle for
weeks alone was my own camels in the
desert or crossing the Atlantic with my
paddle boat or on that tree trunk its
enriched my life enormous Lee and given
a new dimension to my enjoyment of life
survival is medicine for me it's my drug
I've never taken drugs or alcohol the
occasional glass of wine but not to the
point of drunkenness my drug is
adventure planning trips for myself that
no one else has ever taken well kind of
for me a good muttered mm-hmm and I mean
you grew up in the you grew up during
the war you grew up in the post-war
period
you knew the Cold War so survival is a
word that is very relevant in Germany
today Germany's a very realized country
not a very comfortable country yeah
that's the better word for it it is
survival survival trading relevant in
Germany today yeah it's very much
feeling of it's becoming more and more
difficult for people in Germany to
survive because they made themselves
dependent on luxury whether it's
television electronics or computers
they're so dependent but when there's a
power failure there
collapses I've saved myself in a sort of
little oasis when everything breaks down
I can survive alone for a long time so
what do you have what have you organised
what do you have supplies in the cellar
to your food in the cellar for this
emergency or what what's your strategy
in German please if the electricity gets
cut off there's no electricity in
Germany yeah what have you organised
what are you going to do
gets rid of cut it we haven't been
saying it's cold yeah if it were winter
I'd do this up and fill it with leaves
or dried grass or other clothes have a
sleeping bag so I won't freeze I know
that I can go a thousand kilometres or
four weeks without food the colder the
more quickly the food is used up and
then I live off my own body and I lose a
pound a day I've tried it all out of my
own body losing up to 25 pounds and I
know exactly how to test unfamiliar
plants to see whether they're edible I
know her to look for food and if it's
about beetles and worms I watch the
birds
foraging for insects among the fallen
leaves it's all edible it's all protein
Alice protein
rudia Newberg you've been you've been
battling against this terrible
phenomenon of female genital mutilation
for ten years or so now where did it
start for you I read the book from
Juarez dearie desert flower shop that
has flowers and I was shocked when I
read it I knew about the custom but in
the book I found out it's even worse
than I thought
then I found out that 90% of the victims
are Muslim women every day 8,000 women
the world over are mutilated and that
the Koran is wrongly used to justify it
Christian's also practice genital
mutilation but only a few percent and
because I know Islam I know that the
fact that I'm here at all is due to
Islam the hospitality has always
impressed me thoroughly on my trips I've
been attacked twice and I would have
been killed if my companions hadn't
stood in front of me and said this is my
guest if you want to kill him you're
going to have to shoot through me so I
owe thanks to a sloth I learned to avoid
generalizations like when you hear
something about terrorism saying all
Muslims are criminals have a deposit
I've seen the positive side I saw the
opportunity to get the highest spiritual
authorities in Islam to declare it a sin
because Muslims are very devout I hope
that no other argument will be relevant
such as she'll be prayed over animal
instincts she'll become a prostitute or
that smells bad and has to be cut off
when people commit sin no excuse is
relevant that I realized we had to get
the highest-ranking Muslim clerics
together and declare the custom to be a
sin everybody in Germany thought I'd
lost my mind
they said Islam was not capable of
dialogue so on the advice of Amnesty
International I found out the target
organization where there was my wife I'm
friends they made us independent of all
those cowards and skin fighting one
bidet and we were successful right away
but the highlight was a conference at
the Azhar University in Cairo
that's comfortable to the Vatican for
Catholics and they're the very highest
ranking Muslims in the world declared it
a crime that violated the highest values
of Islam it was the Grand Mufti of Egypt
even took over the sponsorship and we
thought the job was done and we found
out that most people were not courageous
enough to talk about it subject was
still taboo people don't even discuss it
in their families so then we document at
the conference and the so-called golden
look in several languages a sermon
template for the Imams and millions of
mosques and a pleaded for luggage for
the Imam or Indian million from morphine
in a number of different languages in
lots of different languages yeah these
are three but meanwhile we have it in
ten language with me there but it is as
I said a template for Imams sermons and
the Grand Mufti of Egypt the second
highest ranking the cleric in the Sunni
hierarchy honored the book or the
fantastic forward any moms were
snatching it from our hands but then
again there was disappointment most
don't have the courage to talk about it
in the mosque
stepheson now it's got its own website
in which will at some point be in all
languages such as Somali because many
Muslims including your moms can only
understand Quranic Arabic not spoken
Arabic Bobby okay like everything else
you've done in life it's an absolutely
fascinating journey and and you've
achieved a great great deal I want to go
back just a little bit though first of
all this is a very old practice it's
five thousand years old it's a tradition
yeah many people in there in the regions
where this is widely practiced will say
to you it is a tradition it is part of
our culture but it's against God it's
against a woman it's against any law
it's against God and and this hurt most
of space that's why it must be started
when we show the pictures to the clerics
at Elisha are some of them 80 year old
men
brown-skinned men turned pale at the
sight of them some had tears in their
eyes hold on I got inflows to all that's
that's interesting then that means that
these men they had never seen this
before this was new for gun among women
or by a hairdresser is it only women
only women who do the circumcision Li
usually and it's there it's there
jaundice hub adds the good that they saw
listen to doctors internationally
renowned doctors who also said this is
the greatest civil war of all times for
5000 years people man against women
still claiming 8000 victims a day with
infibulation the most drastic form a
third of the women died that's a UN
estimate and when they saw the pictures
these men summoned the courage to change
the views that they had held all their
lives they declared the custom of sin I
bowed down in humility before those men
you have been your voice your voice
literally has been heard by some very
important people yeah in Egypt and
elsewhere in Cairo yeah why why did they
listen to you you're a you're a white
German yeah outsider why do they listen
to you yeah do you suck you me oh yes
everybody says that they say Islam is
not capable of dialogue they'll cut your
throat I say all you read here is the
tabloids just as with Christians there
are also criminals who've annihilated
the Indians carried out the Crusades
practiced the Inquisition there are
always all sorts but I've experienced
the positive forces and I intend to
activate them and now I approach them
with respect in humility I go as a
better one to the Bedouin so to speak
not like the UN with a big delegation
all of them dressed to the nines with
their press spokesman he's tired or you
have to think about every word because
it's going to be in the media the next
day I go to them one on one I go as a
man who's now old earlier I wouldn't
to do that and I've seen something of
what you can change with the power of
your authority it's a crime it's a
mockery of your God and your religion
and then they see the picture and
cooperate okay
another another point that we have to
talk about is 30 I mean here in Germany
we have recently had a discussion about
male circumcision circumcision for men
yeah and a lot of people say okay
where's the problem there's male
circumcision there's female circumcision
yeah via MITM I'm fine I'm concerned my
association has a principle we deal only
with female genital mutilation only with
Islam not with Christians and not male
butyl aja stoning or anything like that
if we did we couldn't achieve our aims
and above all I know from my own
experience I'm circumcised because I
once have an infection I can still
experience sexual pleasure when a woman
can't you can't compare these two sorts
of circumcision of course there are
disadvantages with male circumcision but
they're minimal compared to the crime
perpetrated against women that's why we
deal only with women and Islam and we're
successful and the other religions
Christianity and the others will be
forced to follow because the patriarchs
and Pope's could also speak plainly and
say we're not going to let that be laid
at our doorstep that's what Islam has
now done
you went from the north of Germany to
the south of Germany thousand kilometres
thousand kilometers in 23 days yeah what
we leapt from my neck I lift off my own
body I had to drink from rivers but I
lived off my body fat and then muscle
mass I lost 25 pounds pound every day
what was the longest walk what was the
longest day but yeah walk on the first I
did 50 kilometres a day 50 55 zero as I
got thinner and weaker than it was just
30 only 30 worms when you pull him out
of a dunghill and wrap them around a
stick and grill them over a fire it's
like stuffed cabbage leaves it's all
edible you just have to know that if it
disgusts you you chop the worms into
small pieces and eat them like pills
that's a mental process you have to know
how to feed yourself when necessary
birds eat them and it live - frogs yeah
yes both they're under a natural
protection order now I've given that up
but a raw worm tastes like raw shellfish
they're comparable that's why we cook in
seasoned shellfish and worms there's
nothing better
except pumpernickel nice you slept in a
bivouac yeah how did you make the
bivouac yeah well you slept yeah yeah
yeah that's cool and funny in teeth and
mum I learned that from animals you have
to spend the night in the forest if no
do Falls at night there so it's warmer I
had a fork branch that was my digging
stick I made a hole in the ground threw
him dead leaves into it and nestled down
to protect myself from rain I made a
roof from leaves that way you can get
through the night quite well sometimes
it was very cold it was October and I
walked at night and caught up on sleep
in the Sun during the day and what did
you learn about
that's Deloitte ooh I learned that
people stood there and thought he's got
a screw loose but for me it was the most
important training I wanted to find out
how long I can hold out without food and
luxuries it was an experience I needed
when I first intended to visit the
Yanomami people in Brazil they faced
extinction from an army of gold
prospectors I wanted to approach the
indigenous people through the jungle
alone naked was nothing but a harmonica
and bathing trunks a signal to them
right away that I was not a gold
prospector but a friend
he's been unformed so what happened to
you you left Germany you went to Brazil
and he got out of the plane at the
airport in Brazil you went into the
jungle
you dropped yeah no man up you about yes
but like an ordinary citizen then I went
up the Rio Negro in a boat there I paid
a fisherman to take me up two rivers in
his little canoe with an outboard motor
14 days on the edge of humanity and
there in a rainforest as big as
Switzerland lived the Yanomami and
they'd almost been wiped out by 65,000
ironed gold prospectors
those guys had 400 planes it was like an
army and everything was run mafia-style
everyone right up to the president knew
but back then there was no satellite
imagery made public otherwise people
would have been able to see him and then
I came along I hired out as a gold
prospector with a friend who secretly
filmed it off we showed the film to the
World Bank the UN and gradually a grin
on German TV at 8:00 p.m. Greenpeace was
allowed to distribute it worldwide and
the film triggered a rethink and after
20 years with lots of campaigning in the
meantime a pedalo over the Atlantic and
a massive tree trunk over the Atlantic
the lobby was big enough and now they
have peace and then the topic of female
genital mutilation came into my life
that was an important experience I
noticed that nobody not even a listener
is too unimportant to change anything
you just need good motivation I had that
because I was an eyewitness and a new
good strategy with Islam was positive
people in the government of Brazil who
respected the Constitution those weapons
are invincible because it's the same but
indeed come on a flood
I've got one of them in my hand I'm
going to go straight to page 202 rüdiger
because I found and on page 202 in the
book here it tells you how to make a
Molotov cocktail yes it's not a cocktail
to drink it's not a drinkable cocktail
but today you might think I'm a
terrorist but I'm really not there are
regimes and mafia like syndicates that
act in a very criminal manner and in
that case a Molotov cocktail is an
affordable way to defend yourself you
don't need anything but petrol a lighter
and a little cloth always fascinated me
with what simple means you can
incapacitate a tank I learned that you
get into situations the way we Germans
did with the Nazis and we relied on the
Allies who freed us from the Nazis and
that's how it is with mutilated women
they can't free themselves from this
evil help has to come from outside and I
met great Muslim friends and brothers
will bring this to an end I fixed on the
year 2020 I may be dead by then but the
many flights run toward our done is
tough so in there okay dokay we're gonna
talk about something however a little
bit more peaceful now and it might sound
strange but I think it is fair to say
that bread is one of the cornerstones of
German culture and we mentioned earlier
that Rudy Gerner burger was a long long
time ago a baker so we are now going to
talk bread but before we do so we've got
a report on a traditional bread
sometimes called the black gold of
Westphalia but more widely known as p4
it's not just Germans who like
pumpernickel this dark rye bread has
long been an export hit supplied to more
than 80 countries around the world
venes also enjoy pumpernickel on a
guided tour through an industrial bakery
and Goethe slow they get to taste the
product though the raw dough does take
some getting used to the pumpernickel
stays in the oven for about 20 hours
it's baked slowly in its own steam in
closed containers at about 100 degrees
Celsius because of the long baking time
the starch in the rye meal caramelizes
which gives the pumpernickel its dark
color and sweetish fine flavor only rye
mill salt water and sourdough starter go
into the bread tastes delicious moist
fresh from the oven
sweet very sweet this flavor is
typically German I'd say we don't have
anything like it in Japan it's heavy
what keeps well and it's very healthy
God support for German style bread is
increasingly conquering the world we
have all sorts of different breads
pumpernickel is our black gold the black
gold of Westphalia
wrapped in foil the bread keeps for
several months minute in up to two years
Germany exports more than 1000 tons of
pumpernickel annually Rudi Kennebec are
you a fan of pumpernickel the greatest
fan ever I did it for years a crispy
half bun with butter and popper nickel I
don't need anything else and in your
survival books that we were just looking
at what pumpernickel would be good in
there is it a good thing to have in your
backpack in in survivable here the
plumbing deals with insects and plants
and overcoming disgust popper nickel has
no place there okay I've got to ask you
another bread question a very important
bread question why is bread so important
to German people I don't know why is T
so important for British people because
it tastes so very good it's it's amazing
how many Germans when I speak to them
and I say to them what do you miss about
Germany when you're away when you're a
nickel yeah bread yeah bread it's the
first thing they miss
okay we're getting towards the end I'd
like to were throw a quote at you you
have said I am satisfied with my life
but I could have achieved more yeah
well Farb any expense under it's been
I'm a late bloomer I didn't realize
until very late that nobody is too
unimportant to change things that are
wrong even if those things are
historical or incredible in their
dimensions like female genital
mutilation and civil war in the
rainforest and nobody all the viewers
and listeners of your show should think
that they're too small if something
bothers him with a good strategy strong
motivation endurance and unfortunately
also luck you can change a lot and I
have one last goal before I bite the
dust because I'm 78 my time is ending I
want to convince the last influential
Muslim the king of Saudi Arabia to have
this wonderful message that me
leading women is a sin proclaimed in
Mecca at the city gates and elsewhere it
is make him immortal s Viet in
entrepreneur
have you any signal that he has begun to
listen to what you are going to say to
him ungodly Sharia and it's incredibly
develop it gets filtered for six years
I've been trying to get to him via
presidents of countries princes and
princesses even in a British newspaper
before I took out a full-page and
politely beseeching him humbly calling
on him but I was dismissed but I still
have a few hopes that I can get to him
and if he knew about it I'm sure he
would cooperate because he would then
not just help all these women eight
thousand every day but also showed the
world that Islam will no longer let
itself be defined by terrorism but by
the positive sides that every religion
has he to the league unit okay we've got
one question the traditional quiz at the
end of the show what's more exciting
traveling around the world that is all
we have time for it's a good way to end
it stays the last words on this edition
of talking Germany our guest
rudiger neiberg the survivor what a life
so far if you've enjoyed his company as
much as I have then do come back next
week if you want to find out more check
out my blog on the website or you might
want to watch the German version of the
show for now though just
you